[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the show is on fx wednesdays at 10 pm
eastern welcome to wrexham oh we love it
rob mcelhenny actor producer writer
businessman also he's mac and it's
always sunny in philadelphia look at you
mogul
how you doing today and you're all
dressed up i i'm just up hey you know i
just did good morning america dan i have
to look oh
okay
i like that i like that my mom just
texted me she said oh wow you're famous
you're on tv
for 20 years
now my mom used to critique me when i
was on sportscenter she would say your
hair
she goes at one point she said are you
coloring your hair and i said yes and
she said stop and then she said that ty
doesn't go with that outfit now would
your mom do that to you big time star
co-owner of a soccer club with ryan
reynolds
um my guess is i'll get some notes i'm
gonna get some notes later on today but
for now it's just all love and support
she's uh she's proud of me that i
finally made it that i finally made it
on the tv after all this time yeah we're
we're proud of you we're proud of you
and you look like you're in great shape
i can't help but think back when you put
on what 50 pounds
for
a season now can you me do you meet with
a doctor to
strategically put on 50 pounds for your
character
yes i actually put on 60 and i tried um
i tried to do it as healthy as possible
so i would go in and i would sit with a
nutritionist and a doctor
and i had to eat you know six chicken
breasts and four cups of rice and and
eventually your stomach just can't
handle it and then the nutritionist was
like look
you can either eat you know a pound
these four chicken breasts and all these
vegetables or you can eat one big mac
and get the same amount of calories
so then i turned to my doctor my doctor
was like look i'm just gonna level with
you man there is no healthy way to put
on 60 pounds in three months so just go
for it
so that's what i did
but is this your robert de niro moment
like you know
were you appropriately noticed for you
know de niro does this for raging bull
and you know we we're still talking
about it did you get enough credit for
getting fat
no absolutely not dan and i i can tell
you i'd like to be a part of the
conversation
we're talking about legendary
performance you're right
i don't know i don't know why this
wasn't mentioned but i'm sure if you
asked my mom she probably didn't even
see the season
[Laughter]
um the worst day you've had so far as
co-owner of wrexham
was what when
wow um i would say
when we um we saw a very
uh
terrible and tragic
draw um it's just something that's
anathema to american sports but it was
i would say like the losses the wins and
the losses they happen um the draws are
just devastating and i had all of my
friends and my family in my bar in
philadelphia
and it was uh the game was actually
being broadcast and it was like so
exciting because everybody had come
together and it was a saturday afternoon
and everybody was drinking and it was a
zero it was a nil nil drop there you go
it was just dev it was just devastating
and learning how much of a soccer fan
were you prior to this
well first of all dan i have to call it
football otherwise i will get stabbed
when i go to wales
football and american football okay
so
so i didn't really know much about
football
at all um
my but it's the biggest sport in the
world
as you know i'm a massive
massive american sports fan
and yet i never really watched a lot of
football
but over the pandemic i was just as we
all were i was desperate to watch
anything there was no live sports for
what a year so i would just go back and
watch all these documentaries anything i
could get my hands on and i started
watching all these football
documentaries uh and then i started
watching the old games from the premier
league starting from the 60s all the way
up did you watch sunderland until i die
i did yeah
and that's what i thought
when i initially heard that you and
pretty boy bought this soccer team
that
i didn't even get a smile off pretty boy
with ryan
i take that very seriously he is
exceptionally pretty okay i actually
call him that on a regular basis and i
appreciate that it's catching on but i
did wonder about that when i heard you
guys were buying this
football club
that if you watch these documentaries
like you understand you can't be a poser
going in there like you got to be like
do you care
and they you know they're trying to
gauge do you really know what this means
to me and how this hurts us when we lose
it hurts the entire town it's like a
college football team
did they test you how did they test you
of how much you love
wrexham yes yes so that's actually
documented in the in the very first
episode we have this zoom with um
with thousands uh thousands of members
of the community that were on it and we
were asked questions about our
intentions about our business plan and
we had to we had to to present it to the
entire town um and and the reason and we
they had to vote and the vote um i don't
want to give anything away but the vote
was you know almost
unanimous um in the app in the
affirmative and the reason is because
they recognize that um i love
i love
my community the community i grew up
with in i grew up in philadelphia and i
love the eagles and the phillies and the
flyers and the sixers with such passion
and the reason isn't because of what
happens on the court or the rink or the
pitch but as you know uh you make a
living out of it sports is storytelling
and that's what we recognize is that we
don't
really invest in the sport itself we
invest in the people that are playing it
and we invest in the people who we are
watching it with and experiencing it
with
yeah and you you just see what what it
means to them and you know when they
talk about uh it's not life or death
it's more than that i think it's the
quote that's uh in the trailer there but
when you go there it's one thing to be
on a zoom call
then you go into the pubs
yeah
what's that feeling like
i can tell you okay so this is really
strange to just put this into in the
historical context um we just purchased
the um the stadium because we're going
to do a bunch of renovations on it and
you have to really look at it more as a
restoration
program than than a renovation because
it's hollowed ground we don't really
have anything like this so our version
of it would be
you know wrigley uh or even yankee
stadium or something along those lines
but the truth is that that that the
racecourse ground was which is the
stadium that they where we play um when
it was originally built
thomas jefferson was the president of
the united states
so we don't have anything like that here
um it became a football ground in 1864.
while we were in the middle of a civil
war the soccer club the football club
that ryan and i purchased was being
incorporated you realize that this this
is this is in their dna
so everywhere you go you have to walk
around with a sense of reverence and
respect
however they also want to win
and and and that's what we we're we're
bringing in a completely different
um ethos and and and trying to figure
out ways in which we can give these this
club uh the opportunity to win and win
consistently you can't use ethos over
there
come on i mean you could use that on
good morning america but you i mean come
on
you can't go
and i'm gonna change the ethos and then
somebody's like
what's let's eat those
no then i go pretty boy said it and then
they're like
but you know knowing ryan's sense of
humor do you ever have to like elbow him
and go hey don't be goofing around here
man like okay okay yes so so yes
this exact thing happened so ryan wasn't
even a massive sports fan he's just he's
an entrepreneur and he's a businessman
and he's a great truly a great great guy
and and i knew that i i wanted to have a
i wanted to work with him in some
capacity i needed a business partner but
he doesn't really understand the culture
of sports and so when we went over there
and and we watched them the first game
that we saw them play they lost okay
so these guys are playing for their
lives they don't have premier league
contracts i mean they're they're
they're they're very modest salaries at
this level
so we lost the game and we go into the
locker room after the game to console
the guys well he went in thinking well
i'll cheer them up and he starts telling
jokes
he's telling jokes to these guys and i'm
like ryan they're not playing your jokes
are not playing your jokes barely play
out in hollywood
but eventually people are going to get
sick of it it's certainly not going to
play in the locker room of a welsh
football team after they've just lost
and certainly they did not so i'm like
elbowing him to shut up
who do you get recognized who do people
think you look like when they they meet
you do you ever get you know a
doppelganger here
yeah so um i get it i've gotten quite a
few but the one that i'm most proud of
um and then was equally humiliated by
uh was i had this i had a hat on it was
really low and i was in pretty good
shape
and i was out to eat and um this guy
comes up to me he's like oh man i'm a
big fan of a big fan i said oh awesome
thank you he goes can i take a photo and
i say sure so we take a photo and he
goes oh man the departed was my favorite
movie and i was like
well pick a guy in the department i'm
happy to be him but i'm not him and he
goes oh yeah mark yeah mark mark i'm
like oh you think i'm mark wahlberg
and he goes
oh
sorry he goes down
you're messing with me you're messing
with me and i go okay buddy and he walks
away so then i'm like all right that's
cool people he thought i look like mark
wahlberg so about a year later i'm out
to dinner with friends and i meet mark
wahlberg and i tell him the story and
how excited i was and mark just looks at
me and he goes
oh i get it
because you look more like seth
macfarlane than you look like me i i can
see seth macfarlane
yeah like a younger seth macfarlane like
a less successful seth macfarlane wait
are you going to take off your shirt
yeah
i'll take off my jacket oh okay oh oh
gunshots i'll do the the mark wahlberg
thing he's always on i know instagram at
four o'clock in the morning he's working
out i know
hey uh congrats on the show thank you
and more importantly don't screw up
rexum
we're trying we're trying in fact we
have a whole episode that's gonna that
airs um
uh it airs next week
um
that uh where we do a whole episode of
sportscenter we have ryan and i
as as sportscenter anchors and we're
kind of talking about this the season
and so i just want you to know that um
as i've mentioned you before when we met
years ago that i'm a massive fan of
yours and i stole everything that i
possibly could from you uh and i hope i
i hope i did you justice
i i went i was out on the set
were we on the sony where were we block
slot okay so we're walking around and
i'm meeting with rob i have a business
venture here i go in and i'm there on
the set and it's a big deal and you're
saying nice things and i'm
going i we're in business together
and then just like hollywood i think i
got
what do they call it the hollywood uh
goodbye or no
they never call you back
yeah i'll tell you that's actually not
what happened i'm gonna tell you all
your listeners right now okay
it was the opposite it was the opposite
i got a call saying dan would like to go
in another direction
that's the that's the hollywood that is
not true that is not true my direction
would always lead to you it's one
direction
oh it's oh what
was harry styles in one direction yes
hell yes he was
see that's how old i am no jeff shaffer
yeah
yes
i'm gonna get jeff shaffer on the phone
and we're going to call you back i could
have been
i could have been your business partner
in wrexham somebody
we could have
dan do you have as much money as ryan
reynolds
i don't think many people do oh no they
i don't think you'd be wait are you only
in business with ryan reynolds because
he has money
he's pretty okay
okay
[Laughter]
uh congrats on your success and good
luck to uh your eagles this year you're
gonna you're gonna win the division i
think so right yeah i like i like i and
i'm i'm a fan of jalen hurts i think
you're i think it's a good team good
offensive line good d you're not gonna
get relegated we will not be relegated i
do believe we we will win the nfc east
and i don't know once once you're in
there anything hey anything can happen
yeah that's true
yeah yeah uh great to talk to you great
to talk to you again thank you for thank
you buddy i hope you made mom proud rob
mcelini the uh welcome to wrexham